Bob good morning how are you good then
tremendous weekend at Wrigley and I
caught a glimpse of poly but before he
could make eye contact with me I sort of
discreetly turned my back okay Pauly you
said you saw a bob but you said Bob
didn't acknowledge you dan I'm putting
that down in the win column that he
recognized me I expected blown off mr.
Costas I'm good what you thought the
scene would be and what the scene turned
out to be Bob close to it well the scene
on Friday night was pretty festive
before the game and then the game took
some of the wind out of their sails and
then I thought that Saturday was sort of
in between and finally they had
something to cheer about on Sunday
although a lot of people came to the
park with some dread because they were
down three games to one bad enough to
lose the world series but lose all three
games at Wrigley with the prospect of
the Indian celebrating on the Cubs home
field so it was kind of strange it
wasn't a celebratory as people expected
it to be but when they poured out into
the streets after game five and a lot of
people stayed around last night after
the game to sing go Cubs go and send
them off on their way to Cleveland
finally last night you got a little bit
of that feeling to see Chapman come in
and you could tell there was some guys
who were overmatched at the plate about
this but I I don't know the last time
have you seen a situation where yet
somebody was that overpowering that
dominant against you know somebody on a
big stage like this no one's ever thrown
at least by a reliable recording no
one's ever thrown as hard as are all
this chapman in the history of Major
League Baseball I can think of in a
different era when it wasn't as unusual
for a reliever to come on in any
situation and pitch this long at least
not a closer you can remember goose
Gossage coming in and I'm not exactly
sure how hard who's got through
somewhere in the high 90s might hit
triple digits on a on a modern measuring
device but he was a frightening presence
on the mound and he certainly had an
intimidating aura about him so maybe you
got to go
back to the 70s and early 80s for
Gossage maybe I'm overlooking somebody
but in recent history someone throwing
that hard that overpoweringly that long
in that important two game know how does
this not work out for the Indians going
back home up 32 well because the Cubs
have arrested Arrieta for game six and
if they get the game seven arrested
Hendricks against Tomlin on three days
rest and Kluber yet again on three days
rest and you wonder if that ever catches
up with him and the Cubs have been in
need of some offense and they get Kyle
schwarber back as the designated hitter
so they definitely have a chance but the
simple math is this the other team is
home and needs one out of two the Cubs
are on the road they need them both spot
cast is joining us I feel like the
Indians are sort of playing the role of
Best Supporting Actor here and I mean
unfairly and it looks like you know
there they have the opportunity to take
on the Academy Award why is it that I
mean I know the Cubs story resonates but
yeah the Indian story is pretty
fascinating as well why hasn't that
resonated nationally here I think three
reasons you take the Cubs out of the
equation maybe it isn't as much of a
national story but Cleveland becomes V
story not just because the Indians
haven't won since nineteen forty eight
and their loyal fan base has had its own
share of disappointments but it's a
great story to link the Cavaliers in the
spring with the Indians doubling down in
the fall in a city that hadn't seen a
major championship since nineteen
sixty-four in any sport to get two of
them in the space of a few months and
almost any other autumn that would be
the story but now you get the Cubs so a
the Cubs have waited longer be I think
this is part of it too the Cubs have
been a story all season long this has
been building all season long because
they're not a lightning in a bottle team
they're not a fluke and I'm not saying
that Cleveland is by any means but this
has been coming they won the division a
year ago or they got in the playoffs
here we go and then beat beat the
Cardinals and got to the LCS they want a
hundred three games but so there's been
anticipation building
whereas Cleveland kind of came out of
the shadows and and into the postseason
and then the third factor is this again
through no fault of the current Indians
team these games are at Wrigley Field
and so all the demons and almost all the
history at least going back to nineteen
fourteen only six years after their last
championship is in the building where
these games are being played just like
in 2004 all the history was at Fenway
Park so I think the venue makes a
difference to is it is it good for
baseball if the Cubs win this you know
I've heard people say that the best
outcome for baseball is that it goes
seven you got a Wednesday night against
only early season NBA and NHL games and
so it ought to get the best World Series
rating for a single game in a generation
and I've heard people say the best
outcome for baseball is that the cubs
lose Game seven Cleveland celebrates at
home that's a great story in its own way
the curse continues if you want to call
it a curse or the longing for a
championship however you want to view it
continues and the Cubs because they are
built to last they're not a fluke team
they come back and contend next year and
the story plays itself out again could
you see Terry Francona getting MVP votes
if the Indians win I don't think that's
allowed you're not allowed to have a
write-in vote for the manager hey there
are people that want to write in on
november eighth one way or the other two
so maybe we'll win yeah i just think
that Francona has been singled out as
you know this master manipulator with
the bullpen and how he's used to guys
including andrew miller i don't know how
this resonates with the baseball writers
themselves if the Indians happened to
win this well I think if they went in in
seven clubbers got a good chance to be
the MVP Lindor who's a tremendous player
has distinguished himself throughout the
postseason and in this world series what
Francona is doing is adding to his
near-certain hall of fame Young
credentials especially if Cleveland wins
the whole time all right ears though one
thing I'll leave you with the all-star
game and the
fact that the Cubs who had Morgan's
don't open up and have home-field
advantage if that is revisited with a
new commissioner and also the designated
hitter if there's any more traction of
having it or not having it in baseball I
guess you're not going to get rid of
that position with the money attached to
it can you see a designated hitter in
the National League down the road I hope
not I like the difference between the
two leagues and I like it in the world
series this way I think it's added
intrigue playing schwarber in the games
in Cleveland Francona showing that he
certainly could be an excellent national
league manager as well handling all the
strategy there the differences between
the way the game is played in each venue
it's added a chess match aspect to it
and it's always been a big part of
baseball the conversation surrounding it
during a game the second guessing
afterwards stuff to talk about God knows
the game so long enough you need
something to talk about so I like that
just the way it is and the only reason
I'm not outraged about the the all-star
game determining who has home-field
advantage in the World Series is that
what it replaces just as random forever
it was just alternating National
League's an American League's turn no
matter what the records of the teams
were in a matter of one team led
wire-to-wire and the other team was a
wild card it just was an alternating
system and if you replaced it with team
with best record that's one thing within
a league but let's say that some team
comes out of a tremendous division that
actually got the two wild-card teams in
its league and they won 99 games and
they go up against the team that won 100
games in a weaker division and the two
never met an interleague play so there's
no way to distinguish them who's to say
that the hundred win team really
deserves home-field any more than the 99
win team that's kind of random to in
that situation safe travels to Cleveland
Bob great to catch up with you thanks
for joining us thanks a lot dance the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you